develop the Melting approximation with
policy gradient methods and thanks for
having me try to keep things pretty
interactive so if anything is not clear
feel free to ask a question let me start
by thanking our amazing collaborators on
this work so this was done jointly with
sharm at u-dub jason who is here and
moving to Princeton soon and Gaurav
who's a student at UCSD who also did
spend a bunch of time this summer here
and thanks to Simon's for at least like
keeping Jason and Gaurav in the same
place because as you can see we all come
from different institutions otherwise
okay
so this talk is going to look at a
particular class of methods in
reinforcement learning and just for
contrast because the morning was mostly
all about value function methods we're
going to talk about these policy method
policy based methods in the stock and
these methods are actually quite widely
used in practice because they're kind of
in a way the most direct approach to
solving the reinforcement learning
problem you want to find a good policy
and you do it by actually optimizing the
value of the policy by by running some
gradient based optimization algorithms
and these methods are quite nice and
flexible in that they can be extended to
handle continuous as well as discrete
states and actions and they basically
work as long as you have a
differentiable policy parameterization
so they are quite convenient in practice
in contrast though that the theory the
theoretical understanding is somewhat
coarse grained for these methods so ok
we are doing basically a stochastic
gradient type method so we know that
with sufficient smoothness of the
objective we will find a stationary
point we can quantify the rates of
convergence for that and so on so forth
but that's not quite satisfying right we
would really like to understand when and
how well do these methods work you know
how long does it take them to maybe find
a globally optimal solution and so on
and so forth right so so that's the
that's the set of questions we want to
answer suppose we were in the simplest
reinforcement learning settings where we
can represent any possible policy in our
parameterization would these methods
find a globally optimal policy when we
don't have such a luxury of representing
every possible policy what happens how
does the approximation error start to
factor in and what if what happens when
you're doing all of this with a finite
amount of data how does that interplay
with our convergence rates right so
these are the types of questions on
which I will try to shed some light in
this talk but before I do that let me
also highlight why this is a challenging
problem so first of all for most natural
mdpi on permit function
parameterizations the underlying
maximization problem is typically non
concave there's a brave new world non
concavity doesn't scare people anymore
so you know there's that that that's by
itself not enough of a deterrent what we
will see is also this interplay is in a
somewhat critical manner with the
exploration problem that is somewhat
unique to reinforcement learning and in
particular when you don't do good
exploration your gradient algorithms
might get stuck in poor local optima
poor stationary points so so that's
something we have to be cautious for
again like how all of that interplays
with function approximation can be
somewhat challenging to quantify so I'll
start by introducing some preliminaries
my the previous speakers in the session
have done an excellent job of
introducing most of the concepts so we
can be a bit quicker about this and then
I will first start by thinking about the
most basic tabular setting where we can
represent any possible policy and then
move to the more interesting approximate
case okay so starting with the
preliminaries we will be in the
discounted Markov decision process
setting so we have a state space and
action space we typically think of the
action space as small and finite we will
for the state space in the initial part
when I am talking about the tabular
setting it's it's good to think of it as
small but
when we move to the approximation
setting state space can be large as we
like there's a reward function I'll
transition operator P and a discount
factor gamma but in zero one we want to
find a pop we want to find policies
which are mappings from States to
distribution over actions so they are in
agents basically decision rule for every
policy there's this object that will
keep coming up which is the state
distribution that the policy induces so
what this says is that if you start from
an initial state as 0 and then take all
actions according to PI and state
transitions happen according to MVP
dynamics then you can look at the
discounted sum of the amount of the
probability with which you visit a
particular state s at different time
steps the 1 minus gamma upfront just
serves to normalize the thing so that
the whole object is still a valid
probability distribution and this kind
of convenient because it helps us write
down things like the value functions
induced by a policy in a fairly concise
manner right so the value the the state
value function of a policy is just the
expected reward under the state
visitation distribution and the Q
functions are basically on this
particular state you took some action
here but then you follow the policy and
then you account for the long term
reward right so these are these are
pretty standard objects now the other
thing we need to think about when we are
especially running policy optimization
algorithms is how we are going to
represent our policies so usually we
want to you know have some space of
parameters theta and each each choice
small theta in the set big theta induces
a particular policy we can represent the
whole policy class by capital PI and we
want to find the best policy in this
class where best is measured in terms of
the amount of value the policy achieves
starting from some initial distribution
over States that's represented by Rho
here ok so we have some initial
distribution over states that we care
about this can be for instance in the
examples before like the initial
initial configuration of a game screen
initial configuration of a robotic age
and so on so forth and we want to find a
policy that induces good long-term value
starting in that state distribution we
want to find the best policy from this
class a very simple parameterization
that I will focus on for a bulk of this
talk is the so-called soft max
parameterization where we so this is for
now in the tabular setting so we have
one parameter for every state and action
the probability of taking an action in a
state is proportional to the exponential
of this parameter we normalize and
because we have one parameter for every
state in action and the functional form
here is such that we can really
represent any possible policy I mean
okay if you want to represent a
deterministic policy you might have to
send something off to infinity and
that's going to cause maybe some
problems later on but there's a pretty
commonly used parameterization that will
we will stick to for the initial part of
the talk
and when we when we in the later part
when we start talking about
approximation then pie will really be a
restricted class and need not contain
the Western constraint policy okay so
what is this policy gradient algorithm
as you might imagine from the name it is
really running gradient ascent on the
value of the policy which is the
objective you know maximize the only
maybe twist to pay a little bit of
attention to you can ignore it for now
its roll will become clearer in the
sequel so sometimes we will the initial
distribution over states from which we
will start our algorithm might be
different from the distribution row that
we care about just as a exploratory
device so so maybe when we are trying to
find a good policy we might actually
like put the robotic arm in all sorts of
weird configurations initially initially
and that's going to be useful to to
explore the state space well and we its
role will become clearer as we go to the
top but suppose we commit to some
initial distribution or States for the
algorithm denoted by mu here then the
algorithm is literally running gradient
ascent in the parameter space and VT
here represents the value the value
function using the parameters the policy
induced by theta T right so okay I
didn't want to use V of Pi of theta T so
I'll always abbreviate that using V T
and the reason okay so so far I mean
this might why conceptually look nice it
might be we don't know I like I don't I
don't really have the MDP in my head so
I might not be analytically able to
compute this derivative and that might
seem like a blocker but the reason these
algorithms have been popular is that
really this derivative is something we
can estimate from data right so this
this is basically a consequence of these
very nice policy gradient theorems which
show that this you can write this
gradient down as an expectation over
states and actions that are
so the state the actions are all chosen
according to pi and states come from the
corresponding state distribution that is
induced by pi and you take the
expectation of this function which is
the derivative of the log policy times
the q-value function of the policy and
this Q value function is the thing we
looked at before which is saying if you
take action a in state s and then follow
the policy thereafter what is the
discounted long-term reward you get it
up without really worrying about the
details the important bit is that you
can you can obtain unbiased estimates of
this quantity from data so we can really
bring our stochastic gradient methods to
bear on this problem any questions so
far about the basics okay and because
I'm focusing on the softmax
parameterization for the initial part of
the talk it really gives rise to a very
interpretable policy gradient that i
want to show you because it will in one
formula light summarizes both the good
and bad aspects of this algorithm so if
I take the value function of a policy
and differentiate it with respect to a
particular parameter for the state si it
takes the following form
so for don't worry about the scaling up
front okay so there are three things
coming in this equation and let's worry
about them one by one so first I have
this symbol a so this is what's called
the advantage function of a policy what
it measures is you are in state s you
could have done two things you could
have just chosen the action a or you
could have listened to the action
distribution that find uses once you
with respect to either of the after
you've made that choice you you commit
to following PI for the remainder of the
MDP still right so you're just worrying
about for for this particular status
that you're in whether you're going to
act according to a or act according to
the policy PI and the difference between
these two basically lets you measure the
effect of a local change you can make by
preferring action a over the current
policies action distribution right and
it makes sense that if an action a
induces a significantly large larger
reward then what the policy gets then
updating our parameters to actually
start favoring this action is a good
thing right it's gonna it's a good local
improvement to make and that's kind of
what this gradient expression is doing
saying that if you see an advantage on
an action meaning that this action
leaving the policy fixed everywhere else
just starting to favor this action is a
good thing go for it improve your
probability on that action so that's
great but then this advantage get scaled
by the state and action probabilities
for that particular si pair which means
if you're a policy that don't real you
don't really feel like improving upon
yourself you can sort of bury your head
in the sand you can say well I'll just
ignore all the actions that have
advantages over me by putting zero
probabilities on them and look I'm
stationary nobody nobody can improve
upon me in from the lens of the gradient
right and that's kind of a problem with
this algorithm that it can have these
bad stationery points if better actions
are not explored by the policy itself
and I it's going to be one of the key
difficulties in trying to analyze these
algorithms
nonetheless we do want to understand
these algorithms so let's let's start
with the most basic case let's say we
have the softmax parameterization with
one parameter per state action pair we
start from an initial state distribution
that is non-negative in every state or
sorry strictly positive in every state
then with an appropriate step size you
will actually asymptotically converge to
the globally optimal policy in the MDP
that's pretty cool
it's saying that you are in this non
concave optimization maximization
problem but the the the gradient based
updates will find your globally optimal
policy now we can we can think about why
that happens a little bit again going
back to this expression sorry what
happens softmax because of the
functional form puts nonzero
probabilities on every action in every
state right unless I mean some parameter
truly is infinite you have some nonzero
probability of trying everything and I
shall make sure that you cannot fully
bury your head in the sand now you have
to you have to be careful because now we
are talking about you know things that
can actually be nonzero but can be
converging to 0 in the limit so so that
the proof ends up being quite technical
for this and really the other the other
reason the proof ends up being quite
technical is because you're in the limit
you're trying to converge to an optimal
policy which is a deterministic so you
really are sending a lot of Thetas off
to infinity is in the limit and that
creates a lot of mathematical headaches
but the conclusion is kind of nice great
question so yes thanks for bringing this
up I forgot to point this out for most
of the talk I'm going to actually worry
about exact policy gradient methods
which means I am assuming you you have
the exact gradient there is there are no
samples involved I'll talk in one slide
about what happens one we once we start
inducing finite samples and the paper
does go into the details there but but
some of
it's actually kind of nice to just think
about algorithms that have good or bad
behavior even with the exact gradients
because all the things we will see are I
mean it's not going to be all like you
know hunky-dory there there will be
troubles that come up now this is this
is totally asymptotic I have absolutely
no idea what the rate is it's probably
very slow I will talk about convergence
rates by trying to fix some of the
deficiencies of this algorithm in a
minute
but this is the exact gradient even with
exact greater because the combination
lock if you start with like yes yes yes
we proved the gradient map is smooth
then no I mean okay yes that so V V do
you smoothness to show that we are
making monotonic progress and so on but
there is still a lot of other things
that need to be done because Thetas are
growing to infinity is that variant of
one of these stable manifold theorem
type things where you know kind of go
backwards from Oh
okay but really I mean the the point is
that this result while it's saying that
the algorithm is doing something saying
shouldn't get us too excited because it
truly is an asymptotic result and I
don't think the convergence rate is
going to be very nice here and Nan makes
a valid point that in some cases it will
be exponential and partly it is because
we are really relying on these nonzero
probabilities which are going to be very
small though so if small probabilities
are worrying us then there's a very
standard solution in the literature to
think about fixing that both in terms of
the solution we are trying to converge
to and the path that our algorithm
follows by actually adding some
regularization to keep the probabilities
policy induces bounded away from zero
right so this is this one and a lot of
these is these are entropy based
regularization so that's what I'm
showing here so we take the value
function of a policy and we add some
penalty so here I'm measuring the
penalty is KL between a uniform
distribution over actions and your
policies probability which can be
further simplified so it's just it's
just like a log barrier keep keeping
your probabilities from going to zero
okay so one thing to so PI theta of a
given us the action probabilities in any
state because because our gradient
gradients are proportional to PI theta
of a given s at least in the softmax
parameterization right so your your
gradient even if you have a large
advantage on some action the gradient
might be very small spurious ly because
the policy puts a small mass there now
one thing to notice by the way this is
like usually people would often do the
kale in the opposite direction where pi
theta is the first argument we found
that this one is actually at least for
theory more convenient and better better
because this function actually grows
much faster when you're closer to zero
then I entropy write entropy is always a
bounded function this this will actually
blow up so that that actually
it's a being nicer in terms of
conversion properties and we want to now
study the following modified policy
gradient algorithm where we you know
take gradient steps on this regularized
objective no I mean people people there
is the there are some kind of informal
things but but not really anything that
has been very rigorously studied at
least my knowledge okay so I think the
secularization does indeed have some
nice effect in that we can really
extract a convergence rate now to
address see scheisse comment so what I'm
saying is that if you run T iterations
of this regularized algorithm the best
of the iterates you will find will be
approximately optimal now the
approximation is given by okay so we
have some polynomial dependence here so
we have linear on state and action we
have a cubic in this effective horizon
we have square root of T with respect to
number of iterations but I am
introducing a new quantity here so let's
focus on that for a moment
so what is quantity M measures is so for
any policy PI M would measure the state
distribution that find uses and the
initial state distribution that you
begin with in in policy optimization how
much bad can their ratio be in any
particular state and the in particular
care about this with 4 pi equals pi star
okay so I mean the max over all states
here is not very nice however when that
max is truly infinite I can actually
give you counter examples where this
algorithm will not work so it's at least
not a completely superfluous dependence
the other thing is by the way so you
know nan was talking about
similar density ratio type assumptions
in the morning the interesting
difference here is that this quantity
for every MDP there is a distribution mu
which makes this quantity finite which
is just the state distribution induced
by pi star so while this is an
assumption about what the algorithm gets
as input its placing no restriction on
the MDP dynamics unlike these
concentrated types of quantities that
some of the value function based
algorithms seem to need of the original
MDP I believe
why does the mismatch ratio you had only
on high star but not on the sequence of
ties leading to what's that's that's all
the proof needs I mean if it would be it
would be bad if it actually needed to
depend on in fact really it only depends
on you could even replace mu here with
kind of like the policies you find along
the sample path it's really the the
ratio between the state distributions
that PI star induces and the policies
that you are producing induce and mu is
just like universal lower bound on that
up to a factor of one minus gamma maybe
one one inclusion is that you invoke the
difference yeah
honor to you here right under the
distribution used by PI star what's your
kind of like advantage whispers Mike
your current politics yes so exactly
like that technical reason is exactly
shows up through the performance
difference lemma where you care about
your advantage under PI star gradient
gives you advantages under PI so it's
the ratio of the two distribution that
effects that can cause problems gee if I
was not caucus so if I assume you is
some uniform distributions for example
exactly yes so that's good SS to the
force a square to converge something yes
keep in mind that we knew nothing about
this algorithm before
yes so okay so two things kind of
important is that like the way I've
described em you need not be a
distribution that you're even inducing
through a policy like if if you can
really like if you have a similar table
environment that you can restart in
different types of states then you know
you might be something that does not
need to depend on mixing time type
properties but if you're right that if I
restrict mewtwo distributions that I can
induce in the MDP you by acting
according to policies then there will be
additional nuances other than the number
of states that will start just a minor
question you've normalized the value
here right so this I have not I have not
normalized the values the values are in
0h okay so then the cubic didn't
authorize it like like two of them are
so it's like if I translate to epsilon
squared it's going to be gamma six 1
minus gamma to the six I I have a detail
term I can show you
the other thing by the way I wanna
highlight here is so right I I always
used to think that exploration is a
phenomenon that you know is about data
efficiency right so it should matter
when we are you know thinking about
finite samples but what kind of is
important to observe here is that we are
actually in a exact gradient setting
there is no data that has come in yet
but the exploratory property of the
algorithm still matter saying ok like in
hindsight it should be pretty darn
obvious if the policy doesn't go
somewhere like you can collect as much
data as you like with it but it's at
least a little bit non-intuitive when I
first saw it Thanks I forgot to point
that out so yes this is there is not a
quantity that we are introducing here
for the first time and the first
reference I know of his caca day and
Langford in the analysis of CPI the same
quantity shows up in trying to show the
global optimality
other questions okay good so okay so
this is our this is what we've seen so
far now you would like to do better and
really the thing that seems to be
blocking us or the thing that seems to
be the reason for this distribution
mismatch is because our gradients are
scaled by the state distribution of pi
so if you could somehow get a gradient
that was not scaled by this quantity
that would be fantastic because we would
get a large signal whenever there is a
large advantage it turns out an
algorithm that does that has been around
for almost two decades now and this is
this natural quality gradient algorithm
I'm not going to give you the general
form of the algorithm yet we will see
that later but I'll just simplify it for
the particular softmax parameterization
because it just simplifies so nicely
it's hard to resist so this is still a
first order algorithm but it is a
precondition first order order algorithm
that uses official information for
preconditioning and when you write it
down for the softmax parameterization
really a lot of nice cancellations
happen and you get this very very nice
update where the parameters are
basically being updated as if you were
doing online linear optimization with
your linear functions based on the
advantage of the current policy and by
the softmax form your policy that they
are basically doing these multiplicative
rate updates with the exponential of the
advantages so that's great first of all
these do not depend anywhere on the
state distribution the Fisher
information took care of that certainly
these are multiplicative weights which
we have again decades of literature
trying to you know give a give us tools
for understanding that algorithm and
indeed we bring those tools to bear and
you start getting some really nice
guarantees now where you can say that
well you will find a policy at a rate
whose sub optimality vanishes at a rate
that is
completely independent of states and
actions quadratic in horizon and one
over t
okay so this is truly a dimensional
dimension three conversions guarantee
does not depend also on the distribution
mismatch coefficient I wanna point out
that people who are studying approximate
policy iteration they they had been
looking at entropy regularized policy
iteration type algorithms and had
derived very similar-looking updates
without necessarily connecting those to
national policy gradient but had similar
similar and but slightly worse results
for the same type of update rule and
since actually again alice is actually
quite simple so I want to just give some
brief intuition about it so this is the
basic lemma that is from the CPI paper
that nan was referring to it really is a
tool to understand the difference
between do policies in terms of the
state action distribution of one policy
and the advantage function of the other
policy and for other purposes we can
pass this lemma in a very functional
form when we try to analyze
multiplicative weight type algorithms
the first thing like specially or
exponentiated gradient algorithms the
first thing you do is you go from you
use convexity of your objective to
linearize the regrette around with the
first order Taylor approximation and
then you study the online linear
optimization problem and use my
gradients well here you basically do the
same thing except this lemma where you
treat this as your optimization variable
this part comes from PI star and this
part comes from your current head right
so you you you just linearize things in
a using a different lemma instead of
Taylor's theorem and then we are off to
the races we are in our standard online
linear optimization setting and what our
route pr8 follows almost immediately you
have to work a little bit harder to get
1 over T by lower bounding the amount of
improvement you do per step but but that
can be done it's really quite a quite a
simple analysis if you are familiar with
the online learning literature
like so that kind of brings us here it's
multiplicative weight so yeah it's
Miller designs with relative entropy so
since we are kind of improving our
algorithms at least in my opinion as we
are going down the table now we would
like if we would like to study
functional approximation
it seems we should take our best
candidate from this table and try to
study what happens to it when we go to
approximate settings and that's gonna be
the second part of the stock so any
questions before here sorry T should be
epsilon here this is yeah this is this
is a one over epsilon right sorry yeah I
switched my rates from the T base to
Epsilon based last moment okay so now we
will talk about restricted
parameterization so nothing much is
changing this is mostly just a recap so
remind you we are we have a constrained
policy class so now we totally want to
compete to the best policy in the class
the way we no longer necessarily assume
that we can find a best
unrestricted policy and maybe a good
canonical example to carry in our minds
I'm not gonna rely on this particular
parameterization the way I was relying
on softmax before but it is it's still a
good kind of extension of it to keep in
mind as a motivating example where now
we think that we have some state action
features for instance like the examples
Mindy was giving in the morning so but
but but unlike the previous case where
we had one parameter for some state
every state action pair now we only have
D parameters for some D which is much
much smaller than the size of state and
action spaces and s can even be infinite
at this point for all I care right and
we want to find the parameter theta now
that induces the best policy in this
parameterization or under a different
parameterization
so now to think about the algorithm we
want to use here now we really want to
look at the general form of national
policy gradient and do apologize there
there are quite a few symbols here so
we'll try to parse them together so
really ok let's start from here all that
natural policy gradient is doing it's
doing a preconditioned first order
update right so you have the same
gradient as before but now you hit it
with the pseudo inverse of this Fisher
information matrix and the Fisher
information matrix is just an
expectation of gradient gradient of the
product where the gradient is of the log
policy okay if if that looks too much
don't worry the specifics don't matter
really but one thing that may be is at
least if you remember that this gradient
also involves the gradient of log policy
times the advantage or Q function then
one thing that maybe might try start
looking familiar somewhere in the back
of the head is that this is looking very
much like a ordinary least squares
solution right you have your something
that kind of looks like X transpose X
inverse X transpose Y where X is really
this gradient and that is actually
indeed the case you can formally write
down this loss function which is trying
to approximate the advantage with some
weights times these gradients and this
would be the OLS solution for this least
squares minimization problem
and this loss function is not new to the
policy gradient community by the way it
was really part of the the the the the
the certain 99 paper where they sort of
also realized that is a pretty nice loss
function in terms of thinking about the
expressivity of a policy class for these
types of policy gradient methods but and
the other they if all of that looks very
technical here is a good example to
think through when we are thinking about
the linear softmax policies then the
gradient basically you can replace by
the state state action features so
you're really asking how well do my
features using linear functions help me
explain the advantage function of the
policy that's that's a measure of the
expressivity of my features that we'll
be using
okay but realizing that what natural
gradient is using is a solution to this
least squares problem lets us write kind
of a a pretty intuitive general
algorithm where okay we will find any
minimizer of the least squares under the
current state distribution under the
current policy then we will perform a
parameter update by moving in the
direction of the minimizer which is kind
of what this thing is doing right
so very similar algorithm does exist in
the literature it's called natural actor
critic introduced in the work of Peter
sanchow but we were not aware of any
prior analysis of that this algorithm
which is which is the goal here to do
that I do need to make a few assumptions
so let's I don't think any of them is
kind of too bad in of itself so the
first one is just saying that these are
gradients of the log policy are
Lipschitz continuous so the policy has
some the log policy is basically a
smooth function when you're soft max
would satisfy this easily if the
features are bounded the second one is
saying that the weights that I induce to
solve these regression problems they
need to have a bounded norm as well
the third one starts to quantify the
approximation properties of our policy
class we are parameterization really so
it says that when I find the best
regression weights here I want to have a
small regression error for instance if
you did the tabular a soft max version
then this epsilon aprox would just be 0
if you did the minimization exactly so
this is really a measure of expressivity
and a form that actually is not strictly
necessary as we will see we can replace
it by something more general but it's
convenient is to assert that the initial
so now we will have both initial State
and action distribution and the initial
action distribution has a bounded
minimum probability over each action
okay so the bottom line is that if you
have these assumptions then you will
find the best parameter in your
parameter set where the best parameter
is in terms of again the value function
with a suitable step size
okay so let's parse the result slowly
first thing is that we we do only
managed to get a 1 over root P rate here
instead of the 1 over T from the tabular
case I actually do know how to get 1
over T but it requires making some
assumptions that I do think are
outrageous so that's why I prefer the
slower rate instead unfortunately our
old friend distribution mismatch
coefficient is back here and basically
the reason it comes up is when you're
that the really the notion of
approximation you would like to control
is under the state distribution of pi
star but in the algorithm we can only
expect to control it for pi and but but
as far as a useful intuition to keep
because you're now talking about how
well does the solution to one regression
problem generalize a regression problem
under one distribution generalize to
doing regression another under another
distribution this is more like regular
sort of transfer learning in regression
and while I'm being very pessimistic
here in terms of measuring similarity
using L infinity norms we do have more
refined measures of when when and how
well can we do effective transfer that
can potentially be brought to bear here
right so the regression based intuition
is actually kind of useful to keep in
mind
finally the effect of function
approximation is captured in terms of
this quantity no support.this
anything that it has on the high star
yeah replace it by something like I can
compete with any theta and I regret with
respect to any theta yes yes that's
that's that's that is our the paper
proofs
best guarantee over yes yes so it's a so
technically yeah your regret with
respect to like a particular theta here
will be for that am that that catering
uses that's a good point
so in the analysis even still epsilon
approximation or concave from and then
you can still use some marriages yeah so
we do we do kind of use the fact that
this is like a regression problem I mean
the but the way to think about it is
that this is like the thing that's gonna
appear when you apply performance
difference lemma this is the thing that
if it appeared you know how to actually
do the analysis by the same analysis we
did before in the tabular case and the
gap between the two is epsilon aprox so
the the the actual like thing that first
comes out is this you try to replace it
by that and pay the epsilon aprox you
basically the same set of features to
realize like all these regression
targets for all right
and it's all positive encounter along
the way yes I mean okay if you have some
fancy way of like here is a policy write
down these features for that policy then
sure maybe you could do something but
here and yes there is the same set of
features being used for every to to
express every policies advantage
function so yes we do require all of
them to be expressible in the same basis
the other thing I want to by the way a
highlight is so with regards to this
regression problem like I said we care
about we can solve this under theta we
care about solving in for instance under
theta star and I swear I'm paying the
ratio of the two distributions so now in
the distribution mismatch I'm kind of
doing like an L infinity L 1 holder
right where I'm pulling the worst case
distribution ratio out but if you didn't
want to pay worst case like you can
obviously knock yourself out with all
possible other holders that you could do
here if you have any information that
for instance allows you to control the
density ratio in some other norm so
that's kind of another easy lever we
have to pull here function approximation
for we will not matter even with
finitely many samples so I might as well
talk about it okay so look the point is
I can the advantage function which is
really all I care about here I can
estimate it from even one trajectory and
that is sufficient to actually run a
stochastic gradient algorithm now to
minimize this compatible function
approximation loss approximately so I'm
not actually going to plug in like an
actor critic style value function here
necessarily because that will indeed
like you know bring another mess of
function approximation that I have to
deal with that that I really want to
avoid and it will also force me to make
these stronger type of assumptions that
man was making in the morning
so the algorithm we do analyze for
finite finite sample setting is
basically you obtain unbiased estimates
of the gradient by just using Monte
Carlo estimates of the advantage
function and that you can just and then
you can just like give basically your
epsilon approximate ever it was plus
something like a regret guarantee that
you get for the online learning
algorithm that you are using to
minimize this function and you can then
easily quantify the the the role that
the number of samples plays and it's
it's it's it's all like like there
aren't any bad surprises there yes yes
no no so yes you're absolutely right in
a way that I only care about kind of an
average of those quantities and so you
could you could probably you could like
put a schedule on how you want these
things to behave but but but the other
way of viewing it is that this is these
are not really quantities that the
algorithm is using in any way right so
it's yes so it's it's an artifact of the
analysis and as long as you write you
have any sequence of epsilon T's which
is maybe large somewhere small somewhere
and so on but along the sample path it
eventually and adds up to or averages
out to something small things should be
well-behaved but at least the nice thing
is the algorithm wouldn't need to know
how that's evolving so so it's not like
I'm necessarily even imposing a schedule
on those if they end up behaving in a
way that they average out properly
things will be fine
yeah okay that's basically I'm done good
so the goal in this paper was to try and
give finite time convergence analysis
for policy grading methods given their
wide use in practice we in in doing so
we we got a few different a few few
interesting observations one is this
distribution mismatch type quantity
which had been used in CPI before really
also seems to give give a lot of
leverage in in these algorithms
crucially does not necessarily require
restricting the MDP dynamics which is
nice in contrast to some of the
assumptions required in value function
based learning but I didn't talk about
today is we do we do handle like so
everything here was sort of unprotected
gradient based updates when your policy
parameterization is such that you don't
need to do projections if it is such
that you need to do projections then
things get a little bit more technical
and we do give results for that in the
paper as well and finally we this
compatible function approximation law
seems to be a nice way to characterize
the expressivity of the policy class it
thinks all the future directions from
here are pretty natural
so somebody already asked if you know
this KL versus reversed scale business
has been empirically investigated and
and ya doing a proper empirical
investigation there I think might be
quite interesting I mean the other thing
that really seems to be interestingly
different here is I think Mohammed's
question was foreshadowing this a little
bit already that actor critic algorithm
so they the way they've been usually
analyzed is you first worry about the
convergence of the value function which
forces you to make the same type of
assumptions that you require for value
functions value function learning to
succeed and then you just view the
remaining part is a approximate policy
iteration operator the natural actor
critic style analysis here is quite a
bit different and be interesting to see
like if that makes a tangible impact in
any empirical situations as well
this paper was getting pretty out of
hand so we chose to omit any discussion
of variance reduction techniques here
but that's obviously very important when
doing policy gradient methods
practically and it would be important to
study those in conjunction with the
framework we've developed here and while
I kind of keep on you know picking on
these concentrating coefficients for
putting assumptions on an MDP dynamics
they're also more problem dependent
because they can leverage MDP dynamics
which right now our quantities are not
so it would be kind of interesting to
think about what are better problem
dependent quantities that we can use to
characterize convergence guarantees and
finally you know one thing that maybe
seems somewhat interesting to think
about is that if we can characterize how
the initial distribution mu affects the
convergence properties of these
algorithms then could we also observe
the dynamics of the algorithm itself and
use it to improve the distribution mu
itself as a device for basically
designing exploration techniques for
reinforcement learning so I'm going to
leave you with those thoughts if you
want to learn more the paper did go up
on archive just last Friday and I'm
happy to answer any questions
[Applause]
so that's going to take us into the
literate Ori off of policy policy
optimization there we have done some
recent work on that but we we haven't
quite merged the theory here which was
which we only just finished working on
with the with the algorithms there but
if you are if you are in the batch
settings and you want to do policy
optimization algorithms Liang has some
very nice work on policy evaluation
settings and we have some work in the
policy optimization setting that might
interest you I was only in the
continuous space like what a ceasefire
is your handi like analog I mean we you
you can you can still us you might even
in a continuous state space it's it's an
L infinity norm yeah I mean that that's
that's what we formally assume in the
paper but like I was saying the way it's
coming up is you you are trying to say
that I have a small regression error
under one distribution I want to have a
small regression under a different
distribution and when can I do this
transfer and at the minimum like you
could for instance instead of L infinity
L 1 to a different holder like you do L
2 L 2 you end up with like an L 2 norm
of those but you end up with a slightly
worse dependency on the approximation
error so this is there is and more
generally like ok you know shy is not in
the room otherwise he was he would have
told me that he is you know done years
of work on trying to characterize when -
when does learning transfer between two
distributions using all these nice
hypothesis class dependent notions right
and there is no reason we couldn't
leverage all of that very nice work here
so you know it's that's kind of the part
I like about the function proximation
case here that we are
giving the most pessimistic result that
he could have extracted from that point
but there is room to actually do a lot
better you basically show that with
natural gradient policy gradient becomes
very similar to policy formation
yes so what is the advantage then over a
poly situation in terms of the
theoretical balance good very very nice
very nice question so I guess few things
so in the exact gradient setting you're
indeed right that natural policy
gradient and poly C iteration become
very simp similar at least for the
tabular setting now the problem is oh by
the way it's not I mean I would say like
regular eyes policy iteration like all
the all of this entropy regularized
policy iteration really right the
problem is I don't think the equivalence
is quite as tight once we go to function
approximation because now the way
natural that the usual approximate
policy iteration would happen is you
would say well okay I still want to just
do policy iteration for the policy
itself so go do whatever you are going
to do for value function approximation
to because that's that's the and then I
will be sort of completely nonparametric
in my choice of policy with respect to
that value function right I'm just still
going to do something like a max or a
soft Max and here I feel like maybe it's
a the part that is qualitatively
different is that you're actually
finding the best policy from a
parameterization over policies which
sort of the policy iteration doesn't
necessarily give you a very nice way to
think about right so when you have a
restricted policy class I I do find this
viewpoint a little bit nicer at the same
time actually a lot of the theory that's
going on here is in some ways not that I
mean you can construct a lot of
parallels between the type of analysis
here an ALICE not analysis the type of
results we get here in the type of
results for instance conservative policy
iteration gets accept CPI doesn't give
you a compact way of
the final policy like you have to keep
all these policies you found along the
sample path around and after I think
like one of the reasons people don't
necessarily use that algorithm in
practice even though it's a good
algorithm and here like because you you
you keep on updating your parameter you
always have a compact representation of
your policy so so just empirically this
I think does seem to certainly offer
some conveniences and the other reason
is we are interested in these type of
algorithms is that people certainly seem
to be using a lot of these like natural
gradient type algorithms at least from a
10,000 feet level also look very similar
to all these TR pure type algorithms
which people certainly seem to use in
practice so it's interesting to think
about what we can say but yes there are
certainly a lot of similarities with
regularize policy iteration I think you
take further questions of soil so this
one speaker again
[Applause]